hey what's going on is Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday my 25th 2018 what's going on how
are you oh stop it
everything's gonna be fine okay what you
think bad stuff was only going to happen
other people every once in a while come
shake it off anyways oh did I wake up
mad this morning what a surprise
what a unique emotion from the freckled
country you've come to know and love by
the way you know now that all I went
through all of that [ __ ] to get on
[ __ ] Instagram the fact that you have
to follow 9,000 [ __ ] people or you
get the same you just staring at the
same photo every [ __ ] day and it's
just really like it's like a maze you
know you're on Twitter you just [ __ ]
on Twitter now you still have to follow
people I guess now I got to [ __ ] go
on [ __ ] follow all these [ __ ] get
on that's my wife's telling me get on
yeah just follow all your friends and
think of things you're interested so I
can just be another mouth breather dope
staring at my [ __ ] phone I already I
already stare at it too much you know I
thought I was going to get on Instagram
and all its gonna see his ass and
titties and I just not seeing it right
it's probably because I only follow Dean
Delray and Joe Rogan so what I see is
what did I see I saw Joe Rogan walking
around holding a chicken with another 40
chickens following him all right all
these years I've known Joe rogue and I
had no idea that he owned chickens you
know this is causing me to reevaluate
our entire friendship I mean I don't
know why he would keep that from me does
he does he think he can't trust me with
that information these are the kinds of
things I'm gonna ask him the next time I
think I've had him on
I don't [ __ ] know anyways and and and
Dean Dale raised in New York that's what
I know that's all I know
no horse no inspirational workout videos
you know where some guys trying to
inspire you to workout but he's really
just wanted to take his shirt off you
know what's funny about those [ __ ]
it's Instagram people is beyond the fact
that they're doing that show the
inspirational celebrity weather just
everyday you know acting like they have
life all figured out and now they're
gonna pass these gems on to you hey next
time you're thinking outward look inward
to find the real you so your truth can
be you [ __ ] sent to the stratosphere
shut the [ __ ] up and the other one I
love I love the celebrity [ __ ]
standing outside his private jet with
this serious look on his face how about
a smile you [ __ ] [ __ ]
standing there yo this is how we do this
is my Louie Vuitton luggage what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] got an [ __ ]
buys $5,000 [ __ ] pieces of luggage so
some [ __ ] can throw at the bottom of
a [ __ ] United flight you know I I
don't you'd have to fly private for the
rest of your life and watch your luggage
just go easy or you could just get a
[ __ ] bag that's designed to get the
[ __ ] kicked out of it you can keep all
your [ __ ] jewels inside of it oh my
god if I see one more [ __ ] do the photo
shoot with all their cars and then
there's the [ __ ] private jet in the
background what what the what is that
and you know just to [ __ ] just put it
under I'm rubbing it in your face that I
have more money than you don't [ __ ]
do that thing where I'm trying to
inspire you to get to my level
do you realize everything that has to be
involved there like you have to [ __ ]
call up the [ __ ] Airport some poor
bastard has to do they ki have your cars
it's not enough that you have your cars
it's not enough that your flag private
it's not enough that your luggage costs
more than what a lot of people make to
[ __ ] teach kids in public schools you
have to have all of that I mean how many
[ __ ] drivers do you need to get all
your [ __ ] cars out there then you got
to figure out what [ __ ] outfit you're
gonna wear anyways plowing ahead but
that is the kind of [ __ ] that I want to
see I actually kind of have this thing
going on with with friends of mine well
we just send each other all of those
like photos you know that poor kid who
died there the the humblebrag guy he
would have had a [ __ ] field day on
Instagram Jesus Christ I mean that's why
I kind of went on there I just didn't
realize it was gonna be that much work
to try and find all of those [ __ ]
photos because people would just send me
him all the time and I was like Jesus
Christ I'm really missing out not being
on Instagram and then you get on there
and I followed Dean Delray and Joe Rogan
and my beautiful wife and that's it and
Rogan and D del Rey are normal grounded
human beings so it's just you know tell
me who to follow okay I do enough
[ __ ] promotional as other ones I just
want to see I want to see that that's
the [ __ ] I want to see I want to see
people that are pretending to inspire me
but they're really just [ __ ] you know
they want to show me how much money they
have or how great is shape they're in I
mean why can't everybody be
down-to-earth like me I'm sorry I'm just
as self-involved I'm just not as
motivated in the gym plus you know it's
fun even if I got shredded I mean if I
took my shirt off all people would say
is like dude I mean what about Mike what
about my eight-pack ABS nobody cares all
right so let's get to my week here I
when I saw ministry live for the first
time I saw them down at the [ __ ] is it
good at the ho the House of Blues in
Anaheim and I was meeting some friends
down there and they're like oh we're at
the [ __ ] we're at the Ramada oh my
god
so I [ __ ] we're at the bar so I walk
into the Ramada go to the [ __ ] bar
they there's nobody there
turns out I'm at the wrong Ramona who
knew there was more than one room on or
whatever the [ __ ] it was where the hell
I was going so anyways we ended up going
over to the to the show it was just it
was awesome live music was and always
will be the [ __ ] and I got to see them
basically play the entire album their
new album American KKK ant and Al
Jerguson as always just [ __ ] crushing
it [ __ ] crushing it man
you know this front man and then this
front man still has the passion still
you know got the [ __ ] crowd going you
looking around you know a lot of people
like my age but I like the [ __ ]
fourth song there was a mosh pit
I stayed clear of it I definitely stay
clear of it but they got a bunch of I
think there are like a 25 city tour
right now and they write they did
Anaheim and then Oxnard I don't know
where they're off to now
he promote a couple of their dates here
considering such a [ __ ] awesome show
here we go
am I in ministry tour dates
yeah tatata tatata tatata come on man
why is my internet so [ __ ] slow you
know be funny if they actually had it
run at the same speed as your intellect
and you couldn't get mad anymore it's
like well that's because I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm dumb all right they're gonna
be in Sacramento at the ace of spades
importantly the Rosalind theater Hall
that's a beauty that's on Wednesday
Thursday they're gonna be in Vancouver
at the vogue Theatre Saturday they're
gonna be an Edmonton all right
and then when they go into into April
they're gonna be in Montana Nebraska
Chicago Illinois a couple of nights
there Cincinnati
Grand Rapids Michigan Indianapolis
Toronto Montreal and they play in great
places Boston April 17th a couple of
nights there Portland Maine cheese's
they're going everywhere you got to
catch them and that runs through the
[ __ ] is it runs through the end of April
as far as what they have here all right
back to the podcast here so old freckles
forgot that it was Formula One season
and unfortunately somebody on Twitter
said hey you excited for this weekend I
was like oh [ __ ] that's right and
because it's now not on NBC Sports the
ESPN [ __ ] took it over and God knows
they'll [ __ ] it up somehow that's what I
thought they were gonna do I got to
admit I watched what I got of the race I
thought they did a good job although I
don't understand why will Buxton isn't
there now they have like this comedy
team or some [ __ ] they got two people
down there who then throw it over to
another guy you think ESPN would try to
save money and not [ __ ] hire three
people for the job that one guy was
doing outstandingly since I've been
watching but hey I don't run the [ __ ] so
anyways I [ __ ] go on in my cable box
and I go to record the race and I don't
know what happened all I recorded was
the pregame which ended up getting me
like the first ten laps of the race so I
missed the [ __ ] race but then I went
on and I read all about it first thing
that I noticed was the Jesus Christ I'm
stuttering hey there new design of the
the cockpit I'm like what the [ __ ] is
that thing that's like in the drivers
line-of-sight and they got this new halo
thing that they got going on I guess
four years since like 2000 ten or eleven
they've been trying to figure out you
know because it's the open cockpit
people smashed into walls tires and
bolts go fly and these guys are driving
you know upwards one hundred [ __ ] at 80
miles an hour
you get hit with this
you know could go right through your
helmet into your [ __ ] head I don't
know they've been trying to figure out
how to protect them you know and then
all everybody in the crowds like well
hey man don't put it like make it look
like a fighter jet man we're like this
has always been open cockpit man so
everybody in the crowd you know they
want to see it's like listen if we're
gonna sit here along this [ __ ] fence
and at any point a washer can come
flying off the car go through my eye
socket and into the back of my brain I
mean at least you could do is with your
[ __ ] ailment drive around an open
cockpit so they decided to come up with
this new design the halo cockpit design
which is supposed to looks like a giant
piece of plastic to me it's probably
made out of carbon fiber but evidently
that will stop a tire from smashing you
in the [ __ ] head and killing you
nobody wants that right I don't think so
so anyways I saw the beginning of the
race and as always
Lewis Hamilton got the pole position you
know and the race starts and he gets to
the first corner first so obviously he's
going to win the [ __ ] race that's how
it works and even one of the announcers
stupidly said well you know history has
shown that whoever wins the first race
of the year usually goes on to win the
championship I don't know if that was a
comment on how much lack of [ __ ]
passing there is or the fact that
basically Mercedes and Ferrari have such
superior engines that you know nobody
else can compete with them you know I
mean I know other teams like the
American team has Ferrari engines but
that's like this [ __ ] one like they get
the z28 engine we get the [ __ ] rally
sport that's for white trash people from
the 70s so anyways I guess what happened
Sebastian Vettel won the on the
Australian Grand Prix for Ferrari who
went back to the
Ferrari red or I guess less white in
their car the cars definitely looked
different look like a different color
red and I was like there's no way that
there's like a specific red that Ferrari
has to be but it turns out they just had
less white in the car this year they
went on to win it because the Mercedes
team I guess [ __ ] up where Lewis
Hamilton went into pit they thought they
had enough space between the [ __ ]
second place in first place he was going
to get out of the pit first if something
like that I don't know no he was out of
the track I just saw the highlight I
don't [ __ ] them and they screwed up
but you know it's [ __ ] up they blamed
their software so it's just like is
there any sort of like I don't know
racing going on so they got some
computers looking where the [ __ ]
Sebastian Vettel's car is in the pit and
wow how fast they have to be going what
tithe off the computer figures all of
that out
you got an app and evidently the app
[ __ ] the bed and Vettel got out first
you know Hamilton he's always [ __ ]
sulking it was was are you alright
I love Hamilton but he gets so [ __ ]
big up he just starts bleeding it and
whenever he [ __ ] loses I remember
last year something happened in
qualifying and then he just sat in his
car for like [ __ ] remember you were a
kid and you got mad at your parents or
whatever they got out of the car went in
the house you're trying to make a point
you just sat in the car in the driveway
they didn't give a [ __ ] they're like
great I also be quiet but that's your
[ __ ] complainin Aston here so he ended
up winning Ferrari won Sebastian Vettel
came in first
a sulking Lewis Hamilton came in second
Kimi räikkönen he didn't drive anybody
off the track came in third and Ricky
Ricardo Daniel Ricciardo came in the
hometown favorite came in in fourth
place and what's-his-face Valtteri bolt
I guess he crashed her and qualifying
and was given us five spot penalty for
because he changed a gearbox he started
in 15th and then ended up finishing
eighth but I think the real big story
was how well the USA team with this
[ __ ] Ferrari engine that Ferrari
threw up in their back dumpster was
[ __ ] killing at the beginning we were
like in fourth and sixth place at one
point the part of the only part of the
race that I saw and then I got all
excited you know to look up to see where
we finished we finished 19th and 20th
with - not did not finish I guess
evidently we know how to take the tire
off but we don't know how to put it back
on twice in the same race one of the ha
stars went in to get that tire change
they put the [ __ ] tires back on three
out of four were on but one wasn't they
did that the first time and then the
[ __ ] mechanic was screwed it up was
hilarious they cut to the they cut to
the the pit team and he just walked out
of the camera shop I think he went into
the bathroom and closed the door and
probably threw up that he cost his team
one of the cars you know and then the
[ __ ] then they turned around and they
did it again but they're keeping that
chin up they're saying you know what
well you know if you know just think
what would have happened if we actually
put the bolts back on at a Ferrari
Mercedes better look out because we're
gonna be practicing how to take a tire
on and off and when we get that down I'm
telling you things are gonna be real
shook up in the fourth - six positions
this year yeah boy you know what it is
we're Americans we don't give a [ __ ]
okay this this whole [ __ ] the left
turns and right turns yeah we have land
over here [ __ ] [ __ ] in Europe and
everywhere else around the world you're
all [ __ ] overpopulated driving around
[ __ ] corn and old cow
pass that's all I got what else can I do
what do you do when you completely screw
up you know what you do you make fun of
the rest of the world that's exactly
what you do alright let's get into some
happier American news the Boston Bruins
once again we're down they were down two
to nothing to the goddamn Dallas stars
that are down in [ __ ] Dallas now they
used to be the Minnesota North Stars
okay and it was an eclectic group of
incredibly normal-looking people in the
crowd okay
and in the Minnesota people nice people
the kind of people you say hello to or
if you Philly fans you throw full beers
at right then they moved down to [ __ ]
Dallas okay the fake titty capital of
the world
alright you know you know Silicon Valley
out there where they do all the [ __ ]
computer [ __ ] you know and Apple's big
[ __ ] and we'll look at our round
building with the forest in the middle
of it that's where all the computer [ __ ]
happens down in Hollywood's where all
the movies get made out in Arizona's
where they they don't want to celebrate
Martin Luther King Day New Mexico's
where they shop Breaking Bad and then
you get out to Dallas Texas okay and you
basically you have Dealey Plaza and you
have fake titties that is [ __ ] Dallas
and then you have a bunch of shiny
four-door pickup trucks that has never
seen a day of blue-collar work driving
around out there I don't know why I
don't know why you thinking they get
themselves Cadillac everybody's acting
like they got a ranch anyways we went
down then we played them and we were
down to two nothing and we scored three
goals in the third [ __ ] period it was
just and of course I missed the game
because I got the kid now I was at I was
at a birthday party a great birthday
party went out to a [ __ ] farm and all
of that had an awesome time but I didn't
get to see the game and I saw Tim
shallows [ __ ] filthy shorthand
for a nice feed from Brad Marchand
Pasternak had the game-winner and it
seems even though you know patrice
bergeron zout with a broken foot I don't
know if Chara is back last game I saw he
felled the way I used to fall when I was
public like a public skating rink you
know what I mean we do try to stop and
then you catch an edge and all of a
sudden you go like headfirst do a
faceplant before the board's mercifully
stopped you've usually knocked down like
a five-year-old trying to learn how to
figure skate I'm trying to say we have a
lot of injuries but we're still winning
the Celtics on the other hand Kyrie
Irving is going to be out three to six
weeks Sports Illustrated's website is
telling me I don't need to panic Toronto
is going to get the number one seed and
we're probably gonna play some [ __ ] bomb
[ __ ] team and he'll be back by the
end of it I don't [ __ ] know
I think Toronto is looking pretty strong
it's gonna be obviously Toronto and
Cleveland when you think what you think
and can LeBron put his [ __ ] team on
his back once again okay and get to the
finals again while the entire basketball
world shits on him and says how much
he's an [ __ ] and how much I've never
seen a guy who achieved more and get
more [ __ ] I just don't get it
what more does he have to do alright he
took his talents to South Beach alright
he won two championships on a pile-on
team but then he went back to Cleveland
put the [ __ ] team on his back and
beat the Golden State right right there
it should have been over it was over for
Steve Young when he beat the [ __ ] San
Diego Chargers you-you-you was it Chuck
Humphries huge Humphries Chuck Humphries
I don't remember beat that [ __ ] team
one of the most boring Super Bowls there
ever was 49ers went out they had [ __ ]
white pants on it [ __ ] and then the
monkey spent off his back and nobody
ever [ __ ] questioned him again ever
questioned him again even after [ __ ]
Spygate when he said the Patriots should
give up their three [ __ ]
Super Bowl titles you know [ __ ] guys
on TV he's a Hall of Fame player he
didn't realize that that was a brand new
rule and the Patriots were guilty but it
was only illegal for what game nobody
gave him [ __ ] yet they still give LeBron
[ __ ] why is that why do you think that
is
is it because Steve Young is a [ __ ]
more I have no idea anyway so I went to
this birthday party a two year olds
birthday parties from friends of ours
and there was this went out to the
speaking of ranches we went out to this
farm waiting the [ __ ] out towards Oxnard
came a Rio it was awesome it's part of
you know part of Los Angeles I very
rarely go to I fly over it but I never
[ __ ] actually went out there it was
absolutely beautiful out there
path fathima Valley and they had all
like these animals and stuff there big
animal farm and I realized that I am a
big fan of alpacas you know there was
this brown one just with these giant
[ __ ] brown eyes just looking at you a
little weird little em'ly admittedly a
little weird you know they kind of
looked like llamas they're like better
looking llamas you know pot-bellied pig
which I never realized when people say
guy you know you got a potbelly what an
insult that is I mean these things were
fat [ __ ] that belly was lit I was like
on the ground they just like they just
they're [ __ ] pigs
I mean pigs really are pigs they always
talk about how smart they are and that
type of stuff I I think the level that
they eat and the fact that they roll
around in their own [ __ ] it's just
really hard to see the intelligence you
know what I mean I mean I think a lot of
fat people get treated the same way do
you think if Albert Einstein was a fat
[ __ ] like
I don't know rolling around in his own
[ __ ] I mean I don't think we win World
War two what do you guys think care to
comment would you like to write into the
podcast about that one
I'm just filibustering here I got to get
this [ __ ] done cuz I got all kinds of
stuff to do today and I'm waiting for my
advertising and my questions to come and
it goddammit
oh the reads are sent oh [ __ ]
everything's [ __ ] here ready to go I
love it alright let's download these
goddamn things so anyways we were at
we're out there and at that that the
birthday party you want so [ __ ] up
about me let's [ __ ] all the birthday
party stuff I first thing I did was
alpacas I looked at those things and I'm
like wow those things look like a food
source because they said they were from
South America so all up there picturing
is boa constrictors and God knows what
killing those things you know or that
like the Komodo dragon this time he set
this stalk in this giant bull looking
thing and and did those Komodo dragons
they have such [ __ ] [ __ ] breath and
their mouth is so full of bacteria that
if they'd all they got to do is just
Nick and Al an animal just did ten times
its size I just need to bite it and then
they just follow it around for three
days is that bacteria just slowly
[ __ ] kills the thing I just wish the
bull knew that the second it was bit by
that [ __ ] dragon that it was over cuz
then you just you just turn around oh
you're not gonna [ __ ] eat me right
just go over and kill the [ __ ] thing
because the problem with those goddamn
reptiles in my issue with reptiles is
they don't have the D and chimpanzees
they don't have the decency to kill you
before they start eating you they don't
know ya they don't like that thing once
you collapse it just walks up it has no
feeling whatsoever you know which is why
chimpanzees and human beings are the
worst chimpanzees and human beings the
only people I've ever seen get off on
the suffering of something else like it
actually excites them I told you that
thing I saw that thing one time were
they the for the longest time they
didn't think chimpanzees month
eight other monkeys they disproved it
they found out it wasn't true and I saw
these [ __ ] chimpanzees catch this
[ __ ] smaller monkey alright and he
just stood on the things [ __ ] back
and what his fingers was digging flesh
out of its back as the other monkey
screaming and the chip was getting off
on her sec dude like you know how fresh
does it have to be just snap it's a
little [ __ ] neck and get on with it
and ever since then I [ __ ] hate
chimpanzees I hate him I hate him as
much as I love gorillas but having said
that I don't want to see chimpanzees
ever hurt though you know I you know
although I wanted that bull to [ __ ]
destroy that Komodo dragon as it just
kept falling around you know like some
goddamn banker watching a [ __ ] farmer
working himself to death waiting to take
over the land to sell to some other [ __ ]
alright bill let's not get that dramatic
okay it's the wild get mad at God it
created it it well I don't know if it's
a [ __ ] lady or nut I'll [ __ ] up a
human beings is is bigger pieces of [ __ ]
that we are that we actually think God
looks like us and actually argue about
what it's races or insects it's the
stupidest [ __ ] ever okay let me be for
the fun I have like 90 [ __ ] window
windows open and I'm getting rid of all
of these except for my Bryan Kest yoga
videos I'm back into it I'm taking my
power yoga --the watching these things
you know what's funny is i in case
anybody from his class hears this i own
all of this [ __ ] on VHS I just don't
have a [ __ ] VCR anymore so I have
purchased the things but I just can't
play em so now I have to watch them on
YouTube all right where am i where am I
going here I [ __ ] is it ever on the
right email come on you son of a [ __ ]
well why are you doing this to me
loading as slow as humanly possible but
I have to hit pause alright my account
sign out start over again there we go
come on open up you can do it alright
I'm hitting pause this is pathetic oh
wait it's coming up loading loading
loading people just drive busy
yourselves as I wait for this [ __ ]
thing to open up no I don't want the app
oh my god
alright live reads here we are look
who's here everybody it's our friends
old zip talk about how important it is
to have the right employees I'll tell
you right now you know the only thing
worse than having right employees is the
wrong employees like what are you doing
wouldn't it be great if there was a
service that would help you to stop
picking the wrong employee you know what
I mean to hire some person who comes in
ready to work you know not showing up
with fuck-me pumps and tits hangin out
thinking that that's all they got to do
is just look good right
old zipper prudent knew there was a
smart way so they built a platform that
finds you the right job candidates for
you zip recruiter learns what you're
looking for identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job those invitations have
revolutionized how you find your next
tire in fact 80% of employees who post a
job on zip recruiter get a qualified
candidate through the site in just one
day this is also a great way to get a
job right post your [ __ ] resume on
there and zip doesn't stop there they
even spotlight the strongest
applications you receive so you never
miss a great match that's what the right
candidates are out there
zip recruiter is how
find them businesses of all sizes trust
it for hiring needs for all their hiring
needs right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free that's right free
just go to zip recruit accom cyber that
zip recruited up comp slash procom slash
birds if accrued of the smartest way to
hire I'm running out of ways to say that
[ __ ] word oh look who's here
Indo cheeto talk about how every man
looks better in a suit listen I love
checking out the fellas but I'll tell
you nothing gets my freckled motor
running like seeing a man in a well
tailored suit the confidence the way the
jacket blows in the breeze Indo Chino is
the largest custom apparel company guys
love the wild selection of high-quality
fabrics and the options to personalize
all the details including the lapel
jacket line lining monogrammed and much
more here's how it works pick your
fabric choose your customizations submit
your measurements place your order and
wait for it to arrive to arrive in three
weeks or less you can shop online in
Indo Chino comm or visit any of their
showrooms across North America they have
stores I don't think I've ever seen one
this week my listeners can get any Prima
premium Indochina suit for just 359
bucks that's Indo Chino calm when
entering BRR at checkout indoc h i and o
dot-com that's over 50% off the regular
price for a premium made-to-measure
suit plus shipping is free that's right
Indo Chino comp promo code bar for any
premium suit for just 359 bucks plus
free shipping it's an incredible deal
for a perfectly tailored suit there you
go three and fifty nine bucks and you're
out the door you're out the [ __ ] door
alright here's all the goddamn reads
here's all the goddamn reads here's what
the [ __ ] I was
for god damnit hey speaking of that am I
not Tulsa Oklahoma this weekend
speaking of southern accents am I gonna
be down there and over there in a Tulsa
Oklahoma at the Brady theater yes I am
March 30th oh my god I love it what's
today today's a 26 let's see that's
Thursday no Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday
so this sag I'm gonna be at the Brady
theatre Tulsa Oklahoma and then on March
31st I'm gonna be down to San Antonio
Texas right there stars at night are big
and bright deep in the heart of Texas
what do they have there what do they
call that thing that little [ __ ]
River that you the Riverwalk it's
actually really relaxing you know and
then you don't really ever have to get
off and buy anything you just [ __ ]
sitting there floating around on a
goddamn boat that's gonna be one of
those weird flights where like it should
only take me like an hour to go from
[ __ ] Tulsa Oklahoma or 90 minutes to
San Antonio but it's gonna take the
whole [ __ ] day because I have to like
connect through like Denver or some [ __ ]
speaking of which I got some shows
coming up in Pittsburgh April 6th and
for whatever [ __ ] reason the only
direct flight I could get out of LA is a
Southwest flight I don't understand
Philly in Pittsburgh back in the day the
only direct flight from LA to Philly was
on US air I don't mind I don't mind
Southwest until they start telling the
jokes you know and just [ __ ] it's so
goddamn obnoxious because nobody heckles
them that's what's missing on a
Southwest flight booing the jokes you
have such a captive audience everybody's
afraid we're going to crash you know for
some reason you think the steward or the
stewardess actually is flying the plane
so you don't want to give them [ __ ]
right
god that's what I wish I could Reese I
could just [ __ ] see him and that if
he ever saw what those [ __ ] people
became he would hack 'old
he definitely what a [ __ ] apples um I
just sit there stewing in anger I'm not
even mad at the [ __ ] steward or
stewardess is which I still call them by
the way I don't understand how the [ __ ]
that ever became offensive you know what
I mean or they feel like Stewart ahead
more like I don't know comeuppance to it
why is let me look this up why is
Stewart as offensive I might be wrong
here's why flight attendants don't like
being called stewardesses all right
flight attendants oh man they got an old
[ __ ] school one look how hot they
used to be I swear to god they must have
[ __ ] dropped the pay dramatically I
don't know what they used to be [ __ ]
gorgeous unbelievable
all right flight it but the food was way
worse there's always a trade-off right
flight attendants have a job that holds
a lot of prestige in the eyes of most
travelers why there's a giant vague
[ __ ] statement I think that used to
be when that when they were beautiful
women it seemed glamorous the whole
thing the pilot seemed like a [ __ ]
borderline James Bond there's all these
sexy women [ __ ] walking around like
wow they get to go to all of these
places before everybody flew him all the
time people you actually used to dress
up when they went on planes wearing
suits and women would will get all
dolled up and [ __ ] you know this is
before they treated you like a [ __ ]
animal though then they started treating
everybody like animals now people
walking and on they're getting the
borderline pajamas anyways they get
called a lot
different things while doing their jobs
waitress ma'am hey you miss air hostess
and trolley dolly okay you know what I
have well over a million [ __ ]
frequent flyer miles I've never heard
anybody say waitress no one's ever said
hey you air hostess
hey trolley dolly can I get a [ __ ] drink
come on I'm sure everybody has a story
but come on I think pretty much
everybody's been respectful certainly
after 9/11 because then all the stewards
and stewardesses all they have to say is
why you being hostile do you not want to
fly today
anyways flight attendants have a job
okay but one moniker that is pretty much
gone out the emergency exit door is
stewardess and here's why I love it this
person just made up all of this other
[ __ ] waitress ma'am hey you trolley
dolly just made up all of that [ __ ] so
they could get to the stewardess part
all right I think it's safe to say that
a striptease ad for an airline like this
one from Braniff International Airways
below would not fly today yeah a lot of
things from back then wouldn't fly today
at least not in America no oh look at
that
but this type of ad which most would now
consider objectifying towards women was
the only way to go in the sex sells day
okay sorry I was thinking about clicking
on the video I was doing the math
whether I could do that and not get in
trouble because I'm advertising on this
side let me go back to trying to read
this was the only way to go in the sex
sells day of the early jet age oh yeah
because they don't use sex to sell
anything anymore Braniff was hugely
popular in its heyday their flight
attendants wore psychedelic trends from
some of fashion's top designers such as
Emilio Pucci he fell off I never heard
of that [ __ ] guy Pacific Southwest
Airlines was another airline
I'm gonna watch this [ __ ] video let's
see what's going on here Pacific
Southwest Airlines was another airline
press start to play with color course
advertising and here's a bunch of sexy
women winking at me and all is she using
sex to sell in 2018 what is going on
here
it's just another ad this is an ad for
Disneyland oh you know what go [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ] this video is this just
clickbait is that what I've done here
was it nothing can I tell you something
right now I guarantee you all these
[ __ ] hotties that were on this
airline they weren't the ones that
bitched it was ugly women that couldn't
get the [ __ ] job I'm so sick of like
this certain jobs you should just be
good-looking okay and as a [ __ ]
unsightly human being I feel that I can
say this [ __ ] right hey Yankee you walk
into a restaurant you want to see
somebody good-looking you know hotel gym
all of that [ __ ] this [ __ ] thing now
that you don't have to be good-looking
and you could be like you know
overweight and all of that stuff is it's
really not helping out fat people I can
tell you that yes they're getting a job
but they're still eating their way to a
[ __ ] early grave who doesn't want to
live it's sort of what you're doing is
as much as you're giving them a job
you're also in this roundabout way
you're kind of doing this assisted
suicide you're kind of a part of it
right in a food sense I don't know what
I'm talking about but I'm gonna continue
speaking Pacific Southwest Airlines was
another airline that advertised the
attractiveness of its flight attendants
they introduced the miniskirt in 1965 in
her book long legs and short nights
former PSA flight attendant Maryland
Tritt said they used to be a distinction
between flight attendants and
stewardesses flight attendants were
there for safety while stewardesses were
there to be eye candy flirt and serve
drinks yeah
that's your job the pilot passes out do
you know how to fly the [ __ ] plane
well then start winking at people there
sweetheart
she noted stewardesses were not allowed
to do PA announcements because nobody
could understand ok this get a little
weird therefore let's face it they were
they were along for the ride no they
weren't they were like they were serving
drinks Maryland trich Schwartz contacted
me to let me know that I had
misunderstood quote and there was not a
distinction between stewardesses and
flight attendants they merely changed
the job titles once more men joined the
industry yeah these were called stewards
when she referred to stewardesses as
they because she was one herself I
misinterpreted that to mean that there
were actually two different jobs so this
guy really doesn't know what the [ __ ]
he's talking about oh this woman what am
i reading here I don't know many modern
and dare I say older flight attendants
now considered stewardess a derogatory
term toward their profession and even
their personal virtue because they take
their job more seriously that being
there simply to to serve as eye candy
alright I'm done with this [ __ ]
article alright I learned absolutely
nothing other than the astounding lack
of [ __ ] research them I mean I
thought only I did that on my podcast
this [ __ ] person like literally his
article rather than going back and
correcting it he's [ __ ] correcting
himself like he writes the article and I
realized I [ __ ] up but he's just
continuing on yeah I mean at the end of
the [ __ ] day like if I had this is
just I think what really [ __ ] happened
it was flying back then was glamorous
okay it was way more glamorous you got
treated way more it was considered in an
undefined everybody [ __ ] flies they
Jam you in the back you know you have to
pay for food
I mean back then it was like coffee tea
or me was was that was basically the the
vibe back then you know what I mean and
they're acting like I don't know I don't
know what they're acting they were
they're acting like that that there
weren't some [ __ ] women that that was
an appealing job to not everybody has a
dream that's you know something that's
maybe that's what's going on right now
with [ __ ] all these social medias is
that everybody's acting like they're
[ __ ] Joe Montana you know what I mean
that they're like an oscar-winning it's
just most of us would just for
background that's it for that guy in the
[ __ ] middle seat staring is the sub
woman serving them peanuts that is way
out of their league that you never have
the balls to talk to not now everybody's
a winner
according to Oprah you could do whatever
you want it's gonna be great all your
dreams are going to come true nobody's
gonna try to steal your ideas there's
plenty of room for everybody at the top
of the mountain that's just not the case
I hate to say that if just go out and
look at a mountain just look at the
shape there's plenty of room down the
bottom there's you know there's less but
still a lot of room in the middle but as
you keep going higher and higher you
know it's I don't know I don't know what
I'm talking about I still don't
understand why so basically flight
attendants wanted to they're still doing
the same [ __ ] job I don't know maybe
now they they actually know CPR or some
[ __ ] like that they took a couple of
Lamaze classes but you know what are
they what are they gonna do you know
what I mean I mean if like some
terrorists go to take over the plane do
they also have like Chinese stars that
they're allowed to bring onto the
[ __ ] plane please people I don't want
to be called a comedian anymore
I think that's offensive because
people just feel like I'm gonna have a
lampshade on my head I would now like to
be called a humor doctor doctor humor
something I'll come up with it I don't I
don't want to I think it's very sexist
to be called a comedian I don't know
what you know other languages have male
and female things so I think that's a
thing I'm in my business - comedian they
don't be called a comedian we have a
comedian coming to the stage look why do
you have to just make a distinction I
don't know why did why I don't know I
don't know I don't know I'm just can we
get a gender-neutral microphone it was
up that's probably be the next thing
maybe that microphones are shaped too
much like dicks like a hermaphrodite
style one you can have like a dick
coming out of vagina you know something
maybe like those old-school
Elvis ones you could have that and just
have like I don't know what you speak
into looks like a clip I don't know it's
just technically even like still a
podcast let me just get to the questions
this week that went nowhere by the way
and I know a lot of it was ignorant and
I think I stand by it
alright let's get to the let's get to
the questions here jesus-fuckin'-christ
become a pilot you know do that then
become a pilot run an airline you want
respect do that okay you [ __ ] do that
is PTO he's probably people on special
teams all of a sudden want to be treated
like quarterback side it's just you're
not a quarterback sorry oh [ __ ] the all
things Comedy Festival is coming back
again this year and it's going to be a
Comerica theater in Phoenix Arizona and
October 26 Jesus Christ get your tickets
early at Ticketmaster the presale is
Wednesday March 28th at 10:00
public on sale is Friday March 30th at
10:00 a.m. local time both for both of
those and I will be posting the link on
my Twitter and my Instagram and my
facebook just an internet douche aren't
I all right mr. Rogers movie oh I love
it
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
a beautiful day in the neighborhood
would you be mine could you be mine I
have always wanted I can't believe I
remember this have a neighbor just like
you I've always with you so don't call
them stewardesses and don't say hey call
them flight attendants make it seem like
they have a master's degree would you
like some [ __ ] peanuts you will
respect me and my slacks hello mister
neighbors mr. Rogers movie hey there
bill I'm writing to you here from
Minneapolis and very much looking
forward to your upcoming show here you
know Beckett when I was a kid you know
getting treated like [ __ ] motivated you
to get a better job not demand that your
you [ __ ] be treated with respect at
the low level that you had attained in
the job world anyway I was wondering if
you heard about the movie being made
about mr. Rogers starring Tom Hanks as
Fred Rogers coincidentally a movie
trailer was also just released for a new
documentary about Fred Rogers that just
premiered at Sundance and it looks
awesome I grew up watching mr. Rogers as
a kid and it's really refreshing to look
back at some of the clips that show what
a great one of a kind person he was did
you grow up watching mr. Rogers
neighborhood yes I did mr. McFeely
speedy delivery and if so what were your
thoughts about them making a movie about
him maybe you have a different
perspective now that you have a kid
because it seems like there's so much
awful [ __ ] that kids are exposed to on
TV and the internet and Mister Rogers
was a rare TV show which actually helps
kids to become better human beings last
but not least would you consider
auditioning
the show's longtime guests mr. McFeely I
think you'd look hilarious and that
mailman hat went with the spectacles and
the mustache thanks for being a great
neighbor and go [ __ ] yourself
I absolutely would play mr. McFeely I
loved I love mr. Rogers when I was a kid
I like Sesame Street better and there
was something about him that did make me
a little uncomfortable when I was a kid
I will admit that no you know what I
didn't like Lady Elaine and King Friday
I liked to trolley when it went into the
the make-believe land or whatever but uh
I don't know Lady Elaine and King Friday
they just used to make me sick to my
stomach
they just weren't it's funny they didn't
have the personality of like Ernie or
Grover Harry the Cookie Monster I mean
that was just those who like the guys
guys have puppets over there on Sesame
Street
I just thought mr. Rogers neighborhood
was it was just a little stiff but uh
I'm a genetic great lessons I was too
young to understand like all these guys
try to teach me how to be a better
person you know I was just a kid
watching the [ __ ] going wouldn't it be
cool if we had a trolley in our house
then he could get on it and he'd go to a
magical neighborhood and avoid King
Friday and Lady Elaine she was [ __ ]
weird looking too right I'm gonna look
this up here Lady Elaine lady lady body
spell Elaine oh yeah yeah she was uglies
there with them I got lay off the booze
Lady Elaine Fairchild
I never knew her last name there's a
neighborhood and mischief-maker and
having learned from The Wizard of Loop
ovitch off the users her boomerang
toomerang zoomerang oh my god I forgot
about that they do things such as
rearranged the neighborhood I turn it
upside down she's credited with the
discovery of Planet perfect purple which
she found while flying and her something
rather well listen you know that would
never happen now that would be
considered sexist why why does the woman
have to be the bad person well she's in
a position of power isn't that enough
no oh what are you doing come on
all right do i I think Tom Hanks is
gonna do a great job because he always
does you know like I would just said
that like he's an up-and-coming actor
rather than a two-time back-to-back
best actor do I call him an actress now
is that progressive should I not
identify him by his gender I don't
[ __ ] know I don't I don't know what
what to do right now
I think it'd be interesting if they
actually get into his his whole life you
know but if it's just Tom Hanks doing an
episode of mr. Rogers and then I don't
know I don't know what I don't [ __ ]
know i watch sports why would you ask me
about movies all right LinkedIn business
app dear Billy balloon head my
girlfriend and I have been together as
girlfriend one or two words there was -
one word my girlfriend have I have been
together for a year for the past two
months she's been out of work for two
months it has been using this business
app to get work online it has never
bothered me as of reven I think you said
recently as of reven reverently me she
has been getting notifications from the
app I don't know what any of that means
I didn't think anything of it but I
noticed that she had gotten a message in
the middle of the night
Oh as of recently this is a voice text
reverently reverently me as of recently
she has been getting notifications from
the app I didn't think anything of it
but I've noticed that she has gotten a
message I've got a message in the middle
of the night I asked her about it and
she always tells me that it's strictly
professional and that it's just business
men seeking to employ do you think that
app is just to cover up for meeting men
she would meet on apps like tinder I
don't know dude but it doesn't sound
like you [ __ ] trust your your
girlfriend which is definitely an issue
so what you have done you have to figure
out as if you don't trust her because
your gut saying she's shady or is it
some some of your own [ __ ] that you
brought because of a previous
relationship or possibly something that
happened to you as a child calling women
stewardesses I don't know it's possible
women are really good at [ __ ] around
which is why they don't get caught as
much as guys do guys you know guys are
the worst you know we just [ __ ] we
get caught anyways he wants I don't know
I don't know what to tell you to do
there so now you got to start snooping
and then if you get caught and you're
wrong
then what where does that leave you just
tell her it's making you feel insecure
and you just can you just you know and
it's your issue can you just see one of
the texts next time it happens and then
just say sorry I don't know I just love
you so much I was worried that somebody
else was stealing your passions talk
your way out of it that way does that
work I don't know this is not
professional advice he wants to get
married I don't hey Bill your fountain
of cynical humor and knowledge that I've
admired for years yo you are a fountain
out Jesus Christ so I wanted to ask some
advice egg this is not professional
advice my boyfriend proposed two years
ago after I said yes he said he wanted
to keep it a secret since he hadn't met
my parents yet except via Skype calls
they live across the country my parents
kept canceling their plans to visit last
minute so he planned to visit them for
this past Christmas where he would
publicly propose Jesus Christus the
longest proposal ever
I kept this a secret for two years we
only had two fights but each time he
broke off the engagement only to
apologize and make up the next day one
month prior to the trip he says he wants
to postpone proposing due to finances
since we will be moving to another
states after I graduate I understand why
spent five grand on a wedding when will
soon need that to get a house well the
next day he admitted the other reasons
because I had gained weight after
getting on birth control and anxiety met
a you [ __ ] this guy I'm getting a
master's in physics and have a part-time
job so sorry if I couldn't hit the gym
enough well that's no excuse you should
also [ __ ] eat well and I'm not saying
that about him and your relation should
do it for yourself because you really do
not want the health issues that [ __ ]
start earliest in your late 30s and into
your 40s you know I've lost friends to
heart attacks that look like they're in
the same shape as me but I don't know
you got to get checked up just because
you're busy this is what you do you
[ __ ] cook all your food on the
weekend and that you get you got to make
that a [ __ ] priority because it's
going to be stressful enough but anyways
I still maintain at this point [ __ ] this
guy anyways that Christmas was so
depressing but who could I talk to the
engagement was a secret I told him being
engaged was a joke I don't want to be on
this roller coaster anymore or ever
again now he's hurt because he says
marriage isn't is important to him he
does want to marry me just not yet
ha no thanks I'm good he said well we'll
just revisit this later your thoughts
from one cynical ginger to another
thanks for left yeah [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
this guy this is this is what this is
what this guy's an [ __ ]
I want to postpone the engagement coz
you gained weight that's what the [ __ ]
he gonna hit you wag into [ __ ] this guy
yeah [ __ ] that guy
and you seem really strong and you yeah
you know you're getting this master's
degree in physics you'd be out there
design and roller coasters or whatever
the [ __ ] you're gonna be doing you don't
need this guy by the way I watched this
thing that I had recorded you know my
wife why can't when you step on the DVR
right whatever the [ __ ] you call it
nowadays
so we had to go back and erase a bunch
of [ __ ] that I taped I kept all my Super
Bowl highlights and I kept the Patriots
for Seattle and Patriots versus Atlanta
I had no problem erasing Patriots versus
Eagles and I don't know where those
Patriots versus ient games went geez
Ethel Merman all right you want to talk
about a [ __ ] hilarious human being I
got to find this [ __ ] thing Ethel
Merman she was all right we were
watching this [ __ ] thing on the JFK
inauguration which was supposed to be
broadcast by NBC and there was a
horrific snowstorm they were in this
weird venue it was like Frank Sinatra
and Nat King Cole Ethel Merman Milton
Berle
who else Gene Kelly Harry Belafonte Ella
Fitzgerald I mean it was crazy lineup
and Jimmy Durante and all of you this
was like it was a big deal that this is
the first time like marrying Hollywood
and in politics now what we're that's
lettuce is probably a bad thing but it
was just under watching all these
performances and everything so watch at
Ethel Merman and she's literally wearing
just like this winter coat during the
performance because she went there for
rehearsals and she got stuck in the snow
and couldn't get back to a hotel and she
was a Republican and still sang to the
president and rather than all these
[ __ ] douches today this [ __ ] right
did she put her politics aside and she
did it and as she was singing it just
goes like she said something like that
there's there's a [ __ ] die right
there there was a tough broad and I just
started laughing and I said what do you
mean she goes she could just see it
she's she's been through it all a bunch
of [ __ ] guys and she survives she's
seen it all in blah blah so I look her
up and of course knew it was a hundred
percent right she's been married like
four times and she was married one time
for like three months to Ernest Borgnine
and they got divorced all he did was
argue and she one of the things she said
was extreme cruelty so there's a quote I
wish I could find the [ __ ] thing let
me I gotta find cuz I because she said
it so perfectly this is you want to talk
about somebody hilarious that you've
loved a hang out with Ernest I just put
in Ethel Merman Ernest [ __ ] Ernest
Borgnine Ethel Merman there we go the
classic Ethel Merman story all right of
course this is gonna be some douche
turning it into an entire [ __ ] tire
[ __ ] blog goddamn [ __ ] okay yeah
so she was in her brief marriage Merman
was on some [ __ ] she was on some
[ __ ] movie set and she came home she
was all excited because the director had
complimented her saying her she had the
voice of like a 25 year old you know the
face it's just like she was like sixty
all right thirty-five-year-old face and
a thirty five-year-old figure and she
said and then Ernest Borgnine said oh
yeah he can host did he bring up your
old [ __ ]
she goes no he didn't mention you once
something like that I don't know they
like this is this isn't written as well
and what about you sixty five-year-old
[ __ ] and she said nobody mentioned you
at all I've ever seen this thing written
like five different ways she also did it
she did a guest star on some sitcom and
they had a cursed jar and she was in the
middle of whatever sketch they were
doing and that she just stops she goes
what the hell is this going and then the
star of the show was just like Ethel you
know my rule that'll cost you a dollar
and she just goes how honey what would
it cost me to tell you to go [ __ ]
yourself
[Music]
so Ethel Merman Ethel Merman is a I'm a
new I'm a big fan of hers unfortunately
she passed away a long time ago so you
can't go out and have a drink with her
but you seem [ __ ] hilarious all right
let me read the last goddamn question
here so I can move on with my [ __ ]
life why do I keep doing this I keep
going away from my [ __ ] the questions
here this is like unprecedented the
amount of times I [ __ ] this up you guys
have to listen to me
unprecedented for this podcast I should
say all right content here's the last
one the last one is a jealous boyfriend
I love that the women are finally right
knit all right hello Bill burr I really
love your podcast thank you when I was
wondering what your thoughts on a
situation I am going through this is my
first serious relationship my boyfriend
and I just moved in about four months
ago I have all I have always [ __ ]
known that he's been overprotective and
somewhat jealous however I it started to
progress more and more Oh get out get
out
I trust him that he's not cheating on me
of course like many other women I can be
self-conscious and think that maybe he
could stray or do better but I have
never once accused him of cheating on me
not once however he has caused me what
he has caused me of cheating on he's
accused dude these are all voiced texts
he has caused me of cheating on him he's
accused me of cheating on him multiple
times the worst case
of when should have been of which he
made accusations was fairly recently I
just got a full a new full-time job I
was only working part-time minimum-wage
job
which I'm very excited about to have
this full-time job so that he's not the
only one working I feel like I can
contribute now however he started
accusing me of cheating on him with
someone at work even though there is no
evidence he even started accusing me of
cheating on him with his own cousin he's
the one that helped me get the job his
AK use of ten dumped this guy his
accusations are not just him speaking
but yelling hitting walls and scaring me
to the point like he might get violent
ah right here's what you do okay
put a deposit down on another [ __ ]
apartment okay one day when he goes to
work you take a [ __ ] sick day alright
you get a friend you clear all your [ __ ]
out of there yeah [ __ ] this guy [ __ ]
this guy alright you don't want to be
anywhere near this guy you don't want to
be around this guy when you break up
with him he seems like a I don't like
any of this he doesn't even want me to
wear shorts and we live in this area
that gets hot I am not the type of
person to show a lot of skins however
when it's hot I would like to wear
shorts you see what's going on here this
guy's taken over your whole life I'm
just wondering if this if his thoughts
that me wearing shorts is disrespectful
to him to the point he is just a wait a
minute I'm just wondering if his
thoughts that me wearing shorts his
differs disrespectful to him to the
point he's justified breaking up with me
over this I am not sure where to draw
the line oh you should have drawn the
line a while ago uh let me ask you this
if any girlfriend you had was telling
you this story you would be like get the
[ __ ] out right I really believe that I
love and care about him that's the
problem
however when he does when love when does
love turn into more of an obsession also
what is considered an abusive or
unhealthy relationship I would say this
I would really like to know your
thoughts us
right up and I believe you'll be able to
give some good advice especially since
you will not have real bias since you
don't know us thank you yeah you should
get the phone as far as your version of
what's going on you should get the [ __ ]
out of here just the fact that he's
choosing you a cheating on him and with
you with this cousin which is [ __ ]
weird
and then yelling and hitting the walls I
mean you're already out you're already
gone you should be gone and now the fact
that he's telling you what you can and
can't wear [ __ ] this guy so the problem
is is you moved in with the guy so if
you break up with the guy what are you
gonna go into another room and then you
got to worry about this guy you know
doing god-knows-what do you have any
male friends do you have a brother
somebody you know they can help protect
you when you get your [ __ ] out of there
I would get another [ __ ] I mean this
is the type of situation I wouldn't [ __ ]
your pride I would move back in with my
parents if I had to and drive longer to
work get the [ __ ] out of that and I bet
it's the easiest breakup ever as far as
the reasons I don't know cuz you don't
trust me cuz you think I'm [ __ ] your
cousin to the point you're acting like
Jeff Goldblum in the fly and start
punching the goddamn door jambs out oh
and by the way it's 90 degrees out and I
can't wear shorts because you and your
fragile ego can't [ __ ] handle it and
I wouldn't say it this way because this
guy sounds like a lunatic I don't know
what could you say that would just make
this guy go away just say ah you know I
just decided that I want to get really
fat and wear shorts and I didn't want to
put you through that I don't know what
to tell you but I would get out of this
and when somebody violent like this I
would be concerned about your own safety
so like I said I would take a this is
what you do
alright I figured sound like you're
young so you probably don't have that
much [ __ ] so I would just whatever your
friend is that's going to help you move
out you
but the box is together over her house
all right and then bump a bump bump bump
bump a bump you [ __ ] go in there all
right you just act like you're going to
work and then you don't [ __ ] go to
work okay and and I would even tell your
boss just say listen I am living with a
guy I have to break up with and I'm
afraid he's gonna get violent so he's at
work today I'm gonna act like I'm going
to work and I'm gonna clear my [ __ ] out
of that and I think you should be fun
and then you guys [ __ ] and he
probably you want some [ __ ] help you
know because he's a good dude and then
balls so he's maybe maybe he's trying to
[ __ ] you wait a minute maybe your
boyfriend's actually make it a good
point no kidding go in there and I would
just clear all your [ __ ] [ __ ] out and
I would [ __ ] yeah and I would go live
somewhere else and then I would have one
last conversation with this guy and I
would change my cell phone number and
that's it and I don't know depending on
where the [ __ ] you live maybe you can
just he won't be able to find you but uh
yeah this is just this is good this is
the beginning this has the beginnings of
someone that's gonna stalk you and
possibly do something [ __ ] horrible
[ __ ] this guy all right
I wish my wife was here to hear this
goddamn email she's always talking about
you know [ __ ] difficult a person I am
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] print this
email out and put it on her side of the
bed on the pillow I should be making
jokes like this yeah I would get the
[ __ ] out of it and that's it and I would
go find love with somebody that's
excited that you got a new job but
you're going to be participating and
that unless you wear shorts when it's
hot out there you go everybody that's
the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check on on Thursday
congratulations to the Ferrari team for
winning the next one is I believe in
Bahrain or something like that and then
they go to [ __ ] Singapore all right